وحيده وابنها القت بهما ظروف العيش هنا في
داره وائل تعنى بشؤون المراه ايمان
المطلقه مرتين رغم انها لم تكمل عقدها
الثالثه تاخذ معارك قضائيه لاستعاده
ابنتين اخرىين من طليقها الاول تلاحظ مثل
كثيرين ارتفاع عدد حالات الطلاق بشكل لا
فتن للانتباه وترى نفسها واطفالها ضحايا
ذلك
بس ما اعرف شنو نهايت الزواج
والاطفال
شلون اخذهم وبالقانون و بالمحاكم يعني
اطفال حقيقيه
في قرار انهاء الحياه الزوجيه واللجوء الى
المحاكم في بعض الاحيان ومن اكثر تلك
الاسباب رواجا من الصلاه التواصل
الاجتماعي على مست المواطن البسيط يعني
يتاثر بحكم اتاحت هكذا معلومات وهكذا صور
وهكذا مواقع سوف يتاثر بكثير من المفاهيم
وبالتالي تنتقل هذه الامور الى درجه
الخلافات الزوجيه
واستقرار الحياه الاسريه يتعاملوا القانون
العراقي مع طرق مختلفه للطلاق اولها
الطريق الطبيعي وهو طلاق الرجل لزوجته
والثاني والاكثر تعقيدا هو التفريق عن
طريقه اقامه قضائيه من احد الطرفين ضد
الاخر وهنا تتعمد المحاكم تاخير البت بها
بهدف الصلح وفق بعض القضاه اما الطريق
الاخير فهو الطلاق خارج المحاكم دون علم
الجهات المختصه بتفاصيل الحاله
امام هذا القلق المجتمعي وتحذيرات
المنظمات المدنيه المختصه تتعالى الدعوات
لايجاد حلول قانونيه تحد من هذه الظاهره
كتعديل الفقرات الخاصه بالطلاق في القانون
واضافه عقوبات قد تحد من ارتفاع معدلاته
سامر يوسف الجزيره بغداد